what's going on guys i hope you're all
doing well today um so yes i am on
camera for today but
only because i had just no time to edit
this video like i normally would
because the entire morning i was busy
setting up the new discord server so
i know this is a thing you guys have
been asking for for a long time if you
want to be one of the first people to
ever join it
then all you're going to do if you're on
youtube is click the join button there
or you can support me on patreon instead
and you automatically get access to this
server
there are different channels if you're
an anime only or if you want to talk
about spoilers or whatever it may be
so yeah if you're interested in checking
it out we got tons of emojis there as
well like custom emotes
for my hero characters if you want to
check it out then please do
by hitting the join button down below or
you know checking me out on patreon as
well
but with that said let's get into these
questions so the first one comes from
trey cash and he says
what students in class 1a would have
been the worst candidates
to receive one for all yeah so uh in my
opinion the worst candidate would
probably be
uh aoyama and i think for pretty obvious
reasons you know
his body can barely handle his own quirk
and if we remember you know
when deku got one for all he had to do
tons and tons of
brutal training and you know if he
didn't use it correctly his body would
have
exploded in different places so i
imagine that aoyama who
already has trouble with his laser quirk
you know i imagine that one four would
just
he'd probably be thrown up every other
day every other second it should be too
much for him so yeah i think aoyama is
probably the worst
also invisible girl because i just don't
like her like whenever there's something
going on she's always just she's really
sucks she's just never
in the forefront she's never doing
anything maybe it's because she's
invisible and i just don't see her but
for the most part i just don't i just
don't rate her it's as simple as that
on the flip side of that question i
think the best besides the obvious
people like
bakugou and shoto i think the best would
actually be kiroshima
because imagine one for all combined
with like
his hardening quirks so he's punching
people with the power of one for all
and then he can harden his fist as he
does it i think kiroshima
and also he just has a you know he's a
manly spirit he's a he's a true hero in
a way
so i think hiroshima would be the best
candidate besides the obvious guys
now moving on to the next question we
have big anime weeb uh
which is a great username by the way and
this guy is one of my first youtube
members so shout out to you
and he says why did you choose to become
a youtuber
yeah so the reason i chose to become a
youtuber it was like
it was it was not just one thing um i
guess i was inspired by a lot of
different people
so uh i've said this if you watch my
twitch streams i've said this a million
times
but truth hero was the main channel that
i used to watch for my hero academia
videos
and uh and then from him i just branched
out to a bunch of different youtubers so
i watched
groundline review so it's funny because
i'm not a one piece fan but i would
always watch grand line review just for
his descriptions on like
the devil fruits and stuff like that and
so that those all kind of inspired me
and i just you know i enjoyed watching
them so much and i remember like i had
my own ideas for list videos and other
things
similar to what they did and so yeah i
just started with like a few chapter
reviews
and then i started doing list videos and
then i started doing explanation videos
and then eventually my channel started
to blow up properly when i did my theory
videos that's when
it took off like before that it was kind
of just like maybe i'd get like a few
hundred viewers
maybe um but after i started doing
theory videos then that's when everyone
was like yo let's check out telegraph so
yeah that's pretty much it
okay so moving on the next question is
from chronos gw who asks
will endeavour live or die yeah so um
in my opinion you know it's hard i don't
know i can't say for a fact like i don't
want to make a bold prediction
i feel like his character has grown so
much and it's like
at the end of the day i think one of the
themes about my academia is
succession you know deku is succeeding
all might by taking one form you know
he's taking his power and being
the next generation shigaraki succeeding
all for one he's taken his power he's
the next generation
and shoto has endeavours flames he's
take
he has endeavour's power the successes
are all in play
so that means that you know all my we
know almost going to die very
possibly very soon we know all for one
you know
in my opinion chicago is going to kill
him so endeavor when does he die well
it would be pretty poetic if his eldest
son toyotaroki was to kill him
so i think toya should kill endeavour do
i know if it's gonna happen for a fact
no but i would like to see it next
question is from trey cash and he says
if you could pick who would be your
dream team to stop gigantomachia
yeah gigantomachia has a ridiculous
level of strength so um
if i could only use quirks that uh on
the hero side of things
we should start off with mud man so mud
man he can like you know make the ground
soft and he can trip gigantomachia over
we've seen him already do that during
the war so i think
mudman number one because he could make
gigantomachy fall down
then we need someone who can restrain
him so i'm trying to think
i would have said rock lock but i'm
pretty sure his quirk can't be used
on living things and also i don't know
if he could do on something that big
so i'm going to leave rocco out of this
for for a minute so um
who could do midnight midnight if you
can if you can make chagatomakia fall
down
and at midnight would be there to kind
of like use her quirk to put him to
sleep
that could work you know if she can do
it enough i'm sure machia could fall
asleep
um so yeah then once he's asleep what do
you do with him how do you
make sure he doesn't get back up again
if i can include quirks that
are not hero quirks then overall i guess
if overhaul was in his prime and he had
like uh
had his arms then yeah you get mudman to
trip gigantomachia up
then you get midnight to put him to
sleep and then you get overhauled to
come in and he could like
touch machia and maybe like uh do
something i don't know like he can
rearrange mata
so maybe he could just rearrange
tagantomachi's body in a way where he
doesn't
he's not strong anymore maybe his limbs
don't work and maybe just yeah he can't
move anymore
like you can disable him with overall so
um yeah that would be my that would be
my dream team
mudman overhaul and midnight
next question comes again from chronos
and he says do you think
darby will acquire stains fan base at
the surface dabby seems to be carrying
out stains ideals
however we as an audience know that dabi
is nothing like stain
as you pointed out in one of your
previous videos debbie was looking back
at the corpses and destruction of machia
with a pure smile of bliss stain
wouldn't act like that
yeah so you're right in that dabbing
stain they're literally in terms of
their personalities they're nothing
alike
um darby kind of revels in the
destruction of innocent people
where a stain is more you know he hates
he hates bad guys basically
or he hates heroes who he perceives as
fake
so um they are very different in that
respect but i imagine that debbie would
get a lot of stains followers because at
the end of the day stay's ideology was
exposing the fake heroes so what debbie
has done
is expose expose hero society you know
he's he's shown that the number one hero
is not a great guy
he number two hero is also you know not
a great guy
and also he comes from a family of
villains or at least one villain
so by exposing your society in this way
by showing that they're not as
not as as great as people assume i think
that a lot of people who would have
followed stain
by default they will follow derby
because he's parroting the same message
whilst also having evidence to back it
up stay never had evidence
stain was just going around the hero
killer just going around
getting heroes who he thought were not
worthy whereas darby
dabby literally pulled out a dna test
he's like endeavor is my father
he's like devin did this never did that
uh hawks did this i had video like
so dabby's more like the evolved stain
he's got the evidence to back it up
so i think yeah he will get a lot of
stains following moving on to the next
question so this is from uh
big anime weeb and it says what in your
opinion
is your favorite and most hated class 1a
student
most hated is hagakurei invisible belt i
think i said it already in this video
uh yeah i just even in the heroes rising
movie
i was like when i came out of that movie
i was like i remember what everyone did
except invisible girl i just can't
remember what she contributed
so it's like she's just useless so yeah
um most hated is
invisible girl favorite
favorite so um it's a tough one it it
okay it's between deco and shoto to
start with so i would have
deku used to be an easy answer but then
when we got that recent chapter
when he was um he was in the dream world
and shigaraki was in danger
and deku jumped in to try and save
shigaraki
now i agree with deku's ideology for the
most part you know saving people
is a good thing but when you tried to
save sugar i was like wait
that's just stupid like at that point i
was a bit like
i thought i didn't think that was smart
of deku so
yeah i'm gonna say shoto right now shoto
is probably the most intriguing
character besides deku
and uh and yeah after that thing with in
the dream world with deku and shigeraki
i was a bit like
i'm not sure if this guy's my favorite
anymore uh or at least i thought that
mistake that was stupid
whereas when it comes to shoto he's not
done anything where i've been like i've
questioned it too much
because from the beginning we knew what
we knew why he was like the way he was
and he's been evolving ever since then
and there's nothing he's done that's
made me go oh that
wasn't smart so yeah i'm gonna go with
shoto
right now right now shoto the final
question is from chronos gw
and he says what is what is best
entrance
i mean best genius gonna do who is he
gonna fight
and will he succeed so yeah listen best
genius has been missing for the longest
time and it would be kind of lame for
him to come in
you know he's alive it would be late for
him to then die straight away
so i think he will you know he's going
to put up a fight
right now um now this question has been
asked before about
could genus take down gigantomachia i
still don't think
he could permanently do that i think he
could immobilize machia for a bit
you know everyone who tries to take down
machia it always looks like they're
gonna succeed for a bit you know
mount lady it looked like she was doing
something for like a few panels
same with the the class 1a students it
looked like they were about to stop him
for a while
but ultimately at the end of the day
machia will always overcome whatever
you're doing
so i don't think he'll succeed in
stopping machia
he has the power to succeed in stopping
darby but
do we want that you know do we want
best genius to be the one to stop derby
when endeavour and shoto are right there
like it's a todoroki family drama
happening over here
do you really want an outsider to just
come in and stop all that
i don't want that so i'm going to hope
that he doesn't
stop darby i don't think he will stop
gigantomachia
but one cool thing that i think could
happen though what if genius you know
he's made his appearance
what if he tells everyone else just get
out of here he's like deku you get out
of here
back and go tanya everyone go i'll hold
the villains off and i'll stop them from
getting you
um you go you recuperate and you fight
another day
something like that i wouldn't mind
something like that happening that would
be
um you know self-sacrifice i guess yeah
i know i know i said it would be lame
for genius to come back and then die
straight away
but if he was uh sacrificing himself on
purpose
that's a different story um but we'll
have to see but yeah i'm not really
obviously genius you know by default he
might be the next number one hero for a
we know
um because endeavour's hero career has
been totally destroyed by everything
debbie said
um so he's obviously got he's got the
power to to do something
but i just i don't see genus doing the
job by himself
however with that said let me know what
you guys think down below
and of course for the next patreon q a
if you want to uh submit questions
you can be a youtube member you can be a
patreon
and yeah that's pretty much it you can
just submit on those platforms and the
next one will be coming
next month and until the next one peace
out